[Music]
in January of 1953 a tidal surge shook
the North Sea the Titanic waves flooded
the Dutch coastline killing almost 2,000
people 54 years later a similar storm
threatened the region but this time the
Netherlands were ready
as the water swelled state-of-the-art
computer sensors activated emergency
protocols over the next 30 minutes
a pair of 240 meters steel arms swung
shut protecting the channel ahead using
680 ton ball joints the barrier moved in
rhythm with the shifting wind and waves
by morning the storm had passed with
minimal flooding the first field
activation of the mice slant cutting had
been a resounding success as one of the
planets largest mobile structures this
storm surge barrier is a marvel of human
engineering but the my slump heading is
just one part of a massive interlocking
system of water controls known as the
Delta works the most sophisticated flood
prevention project in the world the
Netherlands has a long history with
water management the country lies along
the Delta of three major European rivers
and nearly a quarter of its territory is
below sea level this geography makes the
region extremely prone to flooding so
much so that some of the earliest Dutch
governing bodies were informal water
boards that coordinated flood protection
projects but after the storms of 1953
the Dutch government took more official
measures they established the Delta
Commission and task them with protecting
the entire southwestern region focusing
on densely populated cities their aim
was to reduce the annual odds of
flooding below 1 in 10,000 about 100
times as safe as the average coastal
city accomplishing this lofty goal
required various infrastructure projects
along the southwestern coast the first
line of defense was to dam the region's
flood prone
- Aries these large inlets fed many of
the country's rivers into the North Sea
and during storms
they allowed flood water to surge inland
using a series of dams the Delta
Commission transformed these estuaries
into expansive lakes that serve as
nature preserves and community parks
however this solution wouldn't work for
the new avatar van as the lifeblood of
the local shipping industry this passage
had to be kept open in safe conditions
and barricaded during storm surges in
1998 the completed my slunt kidding
provided the flexible protection
necessary alongside additional barriers
like grassy dikes and concrete sea walls
these fortifications made up the bulk of
the Delta Works project which was
primarily focused on holding back ocean
storms but in the following decades the
Dutch pursued additional plans to
complement the Delta Works and protect
against floods further inland under the
room for the river plan farms and dikes
were relocated away from the shore this
left more space for water to collect in
low-lying floodplains creating
reservoirs and habitats for local
wildlife this strategic retreat not only
decreased flood risk but allowed for the
redeveloped settlements to be built more
densely and sustainably perhaps no city
embodies the Netherlands multi-pronged
approach to water management as much as
Rotterdam a thriving City almost
entirely below sea level when a storm
threatens densely populated older
districts are protected by traditional
dikes meanwhile numr districts have been
artificially elevated often sporting
green roofs that store rainwater
numerous structures around the city
transform into water storage facilities
including parking garages and plazas
which normally serve as theaters and
sports arenas meanwhile in the harbour
floating pavilions rise with the water
level
these are the first of several planned
amphibious structures some of which
house water purification systems and
solar collectors these strategies are
just some of the technologies and
policies that have put the Netherlands
at the cutting edge of water management
the country continues to find new ways
to make cities more resilient to natural
disasters and as the rising sea levels
caused by climate change threaten
low-lying cities across the world the
Netherlands offers an exceptional
example of how to go with the flow as
climate change causes natural disasters
to become more well disastrous how can
we build smarter more resilient cities
and towns explore how we use physics to
create flexible buildings that can
withstand earthquakes or how scientists
are experimenting with a form of
concrete that can heal itself
[Music]